suspens allez-y si il vient de lever le
pôle celui il a un malaise de saint
jacques
mais tous se semblent tous en devient
face et qui glisse au moment où on se
parle et les rapatrier au sol très près
par al mécontents de toute évidence fond
du coeur une âme à l'aise mais c'est
rien de grave et c'est complètement
normal encore une fois les jeunes et les
forces de la gravité voilà il est devant
nous on veut laisser récupérer
on a installé sur la chaîne gulli sourya
à 20 sur 20 et voilà je sais pas ce que
vous recevez les images en direct
oui on les reçoit et j'en reviens pas du
fait que vous êtes si près camarade
david saint-jacques à quelle distance
est voulue en ce moment et bien
honnêtement on pourrait lui leur fait
des questions mais avec le respect qu'on
lui doit on va attendre que ces modèles
afin qu on va attendre qu'ils nous
donnent le pouf la confirmation qu'il
est prêt à nous parler et